the struggle against Thanos may have
gone very differently if screenwriters
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely
had gotten their way in an interview at
the New York Times the pair reveal that
they almost introduced a decades-old
Marvel character in Avengers infinity
war one with vast cosmic powers in fact
that might even be understating the case
the character in question is the
multi-dimensional entity known as the
Living Tribunal and the scope of its
powers over the multiverse are really
quite tremendous unlike nearly every
other character in Marvel lore the
Living Tribunal is a singular entity
with no alternate counterparts in
different universes instead it has
dominion over the entire multiverse no
matter how you slice it this entity is
kind of a big deal The Living Tribunal
is usually depicted as a giant golden
humanoid figure with three faces each
one representing a different aspect of
the being equity necessity and vengeance
The Living Tribunal seeks to maintain
balance and order throughout the entire
multiverse and all three of its phases
must agree that an action is necessary
before intervening in the affairs of
mere mortals however once it does decide
an intervention is in order its
authority is absolute it's all pretty
heady stuff but it's easy to see why
Markus and McFeely toyed with the idea
of throwing such a fascinating character
into the mix for infinity war but seeing
as the film and avengers endgame are
already stuffed with plenty of
characters it's also easy to see why
Marvel Studios ultimately Nix the idea
intriguingly Markus and McFeely
suggested that head honcho Kevin Feige
might have another reason for omitting
the character from the action namely he
wants to save it for a future film asked
if there were any characters the duo
wanted for infinity war an endgame that
they couldn't have Marcus told the New
York Times we wrote a scene in which the
Living Tribunal appeared during the
Titan fight and everyone was like what
McFeely continued he's got 3 heads it
would indicate a whole different level
of architecture to the universe and I
think that was too much to just throw in
the fight on Titan was quite eventful
enough and the sudden appearance of and
as yet unseen golden God with three
phases might have totally thrown
moviegoers for a loop however Marcus
went on to say
the idea is still in Kevin Feige skort
McFeely says they openly worried that
they've just spoiled a big surprise and
that's when Marcus suggested that the
Living Tribunal could have his very own
streaming show McFeely even proposed the
show would be similar to Judge Judy but
really that's just silly are you trying
to justify to me the fact that you're an
idiot
perhaps Markus and McFeely did lab a bit
too freely because we can think of a
perfect vehicle for the Living Tribunal
to receive a proper introduction to the
MCU the Eternals deals with a race of
immortal super-powered beings created
millions of years ago by the Celestials
and tasked with defending the earth from
their evil counterparts the deviants
think about it in appearance by the
Living Tribunal in the Eternals wouldn't
feel out of place at all where it could
have been a little jarring if this
entity just popped into infinity war to
assist the good guys even if they could
have used the help
at any rate Markus and McFeely clearly
have so many ideas it couldn't possibly
have all been covered in infinity war an
endgame even though they're two of the
biggest event films of all time here's
hoping endgame isn't there MCU swan song
after all the six films they've written
so far
all three Captain America movies Thor
the dark world infinity war and endgame
add up to more than a quarter of the MCU
s entire output and all those films
pretty much landed right on the money
no check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about the MCU are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]